one of the best pieces of advice i ever
got was get good at git few things are
more scary for a software engineer than
screwing something up with git after
weeks of writing the perfect code you
submit a pull request and end up with a
bunch of embarrassing failed checks and
merge conflicts next thing you know
you're scrambling on stack overflow
looking for a solution that will likely
just add gasoline to the fire git was
created by a guy much smarter than us he
knew if he made it too easy it would
make us weak instead he wanted to give
us the glory of overcoming the challenge
i'm pretty sure that's what he was
thinking in today's video we'll look at
a bunch of different tips and tricks to
make you more productive with git but if
you're new to git i just released a
short course on fire fireship io that's
designed as a modern learning path to
get you started with git and github it
contains a bunch of short videos along
with exercises to transform you into a
professional git user quickly this
content is supported by viewers like you
and i want to send a huge thank you to
everybody out there who's already a pro
member so to get started i'm assuming
you know the basics of git like you know
how to do a git ad followed by a git
commit to save a snapshot of your code
that's usually the first thing you learn
in git but there's actually a better way
to get the job done you can get rid of
the git add and go straight to commit by
using the am flag this will
automatically add all the files in the
current working directory that's a nice
improvement but there's actually an even
more concise way to get the job done
your git config provides a way to create
aliases which are commonly used to
shorten existing commands or create your
own new custom commands for example we
might create an alias called ac that
runs the add and commit command with
just two letters that allows us to get
things done faster but sometimes going
fast leads to mistakes clearly mistakes
were made what if you made a typo on
your last commit message instead of
resetting and creating a new commit the
amend flag followed by a new message
will simply update the latest commit or
maybe you forgot to include or stage a
couple files with your last commit you
can also update the last commit with new
files by using the amend flag and if you
want to keep the same commit message add
the no edit flag as well but keep in
mind this only really works if you
haven't already pushed your code to a
remote repository unless you like to
live dangerously in which case you can
do a git push with the force flag this
will overwrite the remote commit with
the state of your local code however if
there are commits on the remote branch
that you don't have you will lose them
forever and your co-workers might not be
too happy about that don't make me swing
on you bro but what happens if you push
some code to a remote repository then
realize it's complete garbage and never
should have been there in the first
place the git revert command allows you
to take one commit and go back to the
state that was there previously it's
kind of like an undo but it doesn't
remove the original commit from the
history instead it just goes back to the
original state and that's much easier
than trying to put things back together
like a trauma surgeon
too much blood i can't see a thing in
other cases you may need to work on a
repo but not have access to your local
machine if you're at your grandma's
house without your laptop you can use
any computer that has a web browser go
to github and find the repo that you
want to work on then hit the period key
on your keyboard and like magic it pulls
up a browser-based version of vs code
where you can make edits submit pull
requests and do almost anything else you
could do locally well except for run the
terminal if you do need to run terminal
commands you can set up a github code
space in the cloud which will give you
the full power of vs code and is likely
much faster than your grandma's computer
but now let's switch gears to one of my
favorite git commands stash have you
ever spent time working on some changes
that almost work but they can't really
be committed yet because they break
everything else or maybe it's just
really sloppy and you don't want all
your friends to see it yet git stash
will remove the changes from your
current working directory and save them
for later use without committing them to
the repo the simple way to use it is get
stash and then get pop when you're ready
to add those changes back into your code
but if you use the command a lot you can
use git stash save followed by a name to
reference it later then when you're
ready to work on it again use git stash
list to find it then git stash apply
with the corresponding index to use it
now if you want to use a stash at
grandma's house you're pretty much sol
unless you use a github code space in
which case your stashes would be saved
in the cloud that's pretty cool but now
i have a public service announcement for
developers in the modern era
historically the default branch in git
is called the master branch but post
2020 this term is no longer the
preferred nomenclature refer to it as
main mega or mucho to stay out of
trouble to change it use get branch
followed by the m flag and rename it to
main or maybe get creative and invent
your own name now another command you're
probably familiar with is git log to
view a history of commits the problem
with this command is that the output is
harder and harder to read as your
project grows in complexity to make the
output more readable add the options of
graph one line and decorate you can now
see a more concise breakdown and how
different branches connect together but
if you're looking at the git log there's
likely a commit in there that's
currently breaking your app get bisect
allows you to start from a commit that
is known to have a bug likely the most
recent commit but you knew that the app
was working a few hours ago you can
point bisect to the last known working
commit then it performs a binary search
to walk you through each commit in
between if the commit looks good type
bisect good to move on to the next
commit eventually you'll find the bad
one and know exactly which code needs to
be fixed another advanced git technique
that every developer should know is how
to squash their commits imagine you're
working on a feature branch that has
three different commits and you're ready
to merge it into the master branch i
mean main branch but all these commit
messages are kind of pointless and it
would be better if it was just one
single commit we can do that from our
feature branch by running git rebase
with the interactive option for the main
branch that'll pull up a file with a
list of commits on this branch if we
want to use a commit we just use the
pick command we can also change a
message using the reword command or we
can combine or squash everything into
the original commit using squash go
ahead and save the file and close it git
will pull up another file prompting you
to update the commit message which by
default will be a combination of all the
messages that you just squashed and if
you don't like all the messages to be
combined you can use fix up instead of
squash when doing the rebase to be even
more productive you can also use fix up
and squash flags when making commits on
your branch when you do that it tells
git in advance that you want to squash
them so when you go to do a rebase with
the auto squash flag it can handle all
the squashing automatically now if you
maintain a repo one tool that can be
very useful is get hooks whenever you
perform an operation with git like a
commit for example it creates an event
and hooks allow you to run some code
either before or after that event
happens if you look in the hidden git
directory you'll see a directory there
called hooks and inside of it you'll
find a bunch of different scripts that
can be configured to run when different
events in git happen if you happen to be
a javascript developer there's a package
called husky that makes it much easier
to configure git hooks for example you
might install it with npm then create a
script that will validate or link your
code before each commit and that can
help improve your overall code quality
to wrap things up let's talk about
deleting things let's imagine you have a
remote repository on github than a local
version on your machine that you've been
making changes to but things haven't
been going too well and you just want to
go back to the original state and the
remote repo first do a git fetch to grab
the latest code in the remote repo then
use reset with the hard flag to override
your local code with the remote code but
be careful your local changes will be
lost forever but you might still be left
with some random untracked files or
build artifacts here and there use the
get clean command to remove those files
as well but if you're sick of get at
this point and want to just get rid of
it all together maybe you want to try
out apache subversion to change things
up a bit all you have to do is delete
that hidden git folder and you're on
your own again oh and there's one other
tip i almost forgot about that comes in
really handy if you recently switched
out of a branch and forgot its name you
can use git checkout followed by a dash
to go directly back into the previous
branch that you were working on i'm
going to go ahead and wrap things up
there if you have any additional git
tips make sure to leave them in the
comments and if you want to master the
fundamentals of git step by step check
out the full course on fire ship io
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one